-Our next guest
is an Emmy-nominated actor
you know from his work
on shows such as "Fleabag,"
"Sherlock," and "Black Mirror"
and films like "Spectre"
and "1917."
He stars in
"All of Us Strangers,"
which is in theaters now.
Let's take a look.
-It's funny...
Things are better now.
Of course they are. But...
♪♪
Doesn't take much to make you
feel the way you felt.
♪♪
Back there again...
-Please welcome to the show
Andrew Scott, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show.
I'm so happy to have you here.
-Glad to be here. Thanking you.
-I have been a fan
for a long time.
I think --
I had a weird thing happen,
and I heard
that one of the reasons
you said yes to "Fleabag"
and playing the hot priest is...
that you...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Easy, easy.
-Easy. Easy.
-That you had actually been
sort of playing villains
and wanted to break free
of the villain roles.
-Yeah, so, when I was in my 20s,
I had a little baby --
little Irish, baby,
little puppy -- little face.
And I really felt like I had
this kind of darkness inside me.
I was like, "Why can't I get
get a part as a villain?"
And then that happened.
And then there was loads
of villains happening.
So then I was like,
"Why can't I get a....
Why can't I -- Why can't
people see the real me?!"
Uh, and, uh --
So then Phoebe and I
had done a play together
in London that nobody saw.
Uh, and then
she came a-knocking,
and that's where the priest
came from.
-It does speak to what
a great actor you are
because when I was
watching "Fleabag,"
I had that moment of, like,
"Where do I know him from?"
-Right.
-And even though you look
exactly the same
in "Sherlock" as Moriarty,
like, you were so --
You went from so villainous
to so charming that I thought,
"That can't possibly be
the same person."
-Well, we contain multitudes.
-You do.
-We contain multitudes.
-I don't. You do.
-Yeah. You're all dark.
-Yeah. All dark.
I will say Phoebe, did you,
I mean, the finest compliment
she could ever do.
The fact that she gave you
a character named Hot Priest.
-Well, she didn't, you know.
-Really?
-Other people did it?
-Yeah, The character
was called Priest, you know,
and then it was -- it was --
it was these filthy people
that did it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
That's -- That's the power
of the Internet, you know, so...
She mentions
that the character is hot,
and then the Internet
just, you know...
-And I think --
You know, don't --
You brought a lot to that, too.
Your wonderful co-star
in this film, uh, Paul Mescal --
he mentioned
that he was a fan.
He even dressed up
as Hot Priest.
And that's, uh,
Daisy Edgar-Jones.
-Yes. Yeah.
They dressed up for Halloween.
They didn't just dress up
for no reason.
-Very kind of you for --
They're not insane.
It was a holiday.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Um, this is such a --
This movie, it's hard to talk
about, we were saying backstage.
-Yes. Very hard to talk about.
Yeah.
-It is.
It's very sad, but it's more
beautiful than sad. Would you
say that's a fair way...
-Yeah. I think that's exactly
right. It's very hopeful.
It's -- The basic premise of it
is that it's this man
who conjures up his parents
who've been killed
in a car accident,
and he talks to them as he
remembers them most acutely,
which is when they are
slightly younger than he is.
So he has these conversations
with his parents,
who are played
by Claire Foy and Jamie Bell,
both of whom are younger
than me.
-Uh-huh.
-And at the same time,
he's falling in love
with Paul Mescal.
-It is really something.
It's unlike anything
I've ever seen before.
-Yeah.
-And I expected this
beautiful romance,
and I got that.
-Yeah.
-But also, as a parent,
it was incredibly moving,
this idea that not just
what your kids would say to you
all these years later,
but what you would want
to be able to say to your kids,
which, as a young parent,
you forget
that if you're not around,
you never have this moment
to say, "Hey, I was young, too."
-Yeah, well,
that's what's so beau--
It's just this beautiful idea.
And, you know, we're children
forever with our parents.
And, you know, everybody has a
relationship with their parents,
even if they're not around.
So it's this
really, really beautiful
and very, very hopeful
kind of film.
And, yeah, I think
that's what the film is --
is just taking off now.
So it's so beautiful to hear
everybody's reaction to it.
-There's a really wonderful
scene
where you're sort of
visiting with your parents
and you're wearing --
As an adult,
you're wearing child's pajamas.
Now, they're sized for you.
-Yes.
-And it's one of the most
heartbreaking scenes
in the film.
But I also couldn't help
but think when they said, "Cut,"
you were just basically
in mortifying pajamas.
-You know those polyester
pajamas that you have
when you're a child
and you have such a --
I just looked ridiculous.
Talk about un-hot. Un-hot.
There was no --
There was no Hot Priest there,
but, uh, yeah, it was, um...
Yeah, it seems absurd,
but it was -- it's very moving.
-It's very moving.
I will say I've also seen
a lot of press
with you and Paul.
Uh, you seem like
very good friends.
You seem to have a lot of laughs
with each other.
And yet this film
is sort of almost --
You know, it's so serious.
-It's -- Yeah.
-Was it easy for you
to go both in and out of scenes
and also just sort of
have a lightness
that is obviously there
in your friendship?
-Oh, totally.
When you're doing a sad --
when you're doing anything sad,
you always have the most fun.
You really do
because you can't ---
You can't spend your whole day
crying into the darkness.
Do you know what I mean?
You really can't.
And, uh, yeah,
I remember when I --
when I played Hamlet,
we had such a laugh backstage,
and then you're going on
and you're, like,
talking about, you know,
really, you know --
You're literally talking
about life and death.
But, yeah, you got to have
a bit of light in shade.
-That's true. And, by the way,
on sets of comedies,
like, that's where -- The minute
anybody says, "Cut,"
everybody's like,
"Was that funny?"
-Exactly. You have people
on headphones going,
"That's funny. Yeah.
That's funny.
Yeah, yeah. Mm-hmm.
Yeah, yeah. It's true.
It's really true.
But such is life.
-You asked about the response,
and I know you've been out
doing a lot of press.
I mean,
making a movie like this
that is so unlike anything else,
um, has it been --
has it been wonderful
the way it's being received?
I have to imagine it is.
-It's been phenomenal. It's...
It's a film that's really,
really difficult to talk to,
but to see the film, I believe,
is to love the film.
I really do.
I think it affects people
in this extraordinary way.
People are, like,
leaving the cinema.
And it's not depressing,
as you say,
but it's -- I'm determined
that people don't think
it's a really depressing thing.
But it's so -- it's sort of
cathartic and moving.
It's very emotional.
It's about families.
And people just love that.
People like a good cry
in the cinema.
-I agree.
-You know.
And there's a bit
of romance in there,
and it's really,
really beautiful.
So please just go and see it!
-I will say this.
Do you...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do you find
you're more emotional
when you see a movie
on a plane?
-Oh, my God. I had to be --
I had to be the --
I remember the air steward
had to say,
"Are you alright, sir?"
Because I was watching --
You know the first 20 minutes
of "Up"?
Ever seen "Up"?
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
-Oh, my God.
I fell on this...
-They shouldn't allow that
on a plane. Yeah.
-Oh, my God.
I was fully, like --
[Sobbing] kind of crying.
-Because I will say
there's often times where --
You know, I have
a lot of guests on the show.
Sometimes I have to, like,
catch the films or I can't.
I can't always go see them
in the cinema.
I don't watch them
the best way.
Sometimes I'm watching them
on a laptop in an office.
-Yeah.
And this movie was still
getting me so much,
and I had a moment of like...
Oh, my God, if people
watch this on a plane,
there should be
an announcement saying,
"You have to let
the people in your row
know you're about to do this.
-Exactly.
-So they don't come to us
and be like,
"Somebody's having
a mental breakdown."
-Yeah.
"We're about to serve lunch.
and "All of Us Strangers"
is about to start.
Please assemble your tissues."
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's a very
astute point, actually.
If it makes it to the planes.
How do they choose
what goes on there?
-I don't know.
Do you want to ask now?
-That's not for now.
-No, no. Let's --
But, you know,
if you want to --
If you have any favorite
airlines that you want to,
you know, basically ask
right now to have it.
-I do, but I couldn't --
I couldn't cheapen myself
in that way.
-Very good. That was a trap.
We laid out a trap for you.
-Thank you. Thanking you!
-Yeah.
Um, another thing
about a film like this.
You know, it's a very --
it's a very small cast,
and that must be
a wonderful part
because, you know, you mentioned
doing a play, you know,
with Phoebe or working
with Paul on stage.
It must at some point feel
a little bit like not a play,
but a play's cast.
Like, a small group
of people that get to...
-Yeah, well,
if there's only the four of you,
you could get sick
looking at each other.
And then -- [ Laughs ]
But the subject matter
is so epic, you know?
You'll see it when you guys
go and see the movie.
Uh, you know,
it's such a huge subject matter.
So it's kind of nice,
the juxtaposition between
these tiny little things,
these stories that we think
within our own families
are just so precious to us,
but actually, you know,
they're huge.
You know, our own life story
is the most important thing
in our world.
So, um, yeah, it was
really, really intimate.
And we shot it
in the childhood home --
It's about this man
who goes back
to his childhood home.
And we shot it
in the childhood home,
actual childhood home
of our director, Andrew Haigh.
-No way.
-So we went into this little
suburban house, and he was --
Of course, he wrote the film,
and he was imagining his
own house, as you might do.
And then he knocked on the door
of his childhood house,
and he was like,
"Hello. I used to live here."
And mercifully,
they hadn't put a big
disgusting extension onto it.
-Yeah.
-And so, uh, we were able
to use it as a 1980s home.
-Really?
-So it was extraordinary!
-I kept looking at him going,
"Are you not --
Is this not freaking you out
that you would have, like,
been crying
in this little bathroom
and all our crew's
stomping all over it?"
But actually it provided
a real intimacy
to the atmosphere, you know,
because you feel like you
were really --
Even though
it's not a true story,
you feel like you're
representing somebody.
-Well, it was really
something special.
I'm so glad I saw it.
Everybody should see it.
Thanks for being here, man.
What a pleasure.
-Thank you so much.
-Andrew Scott, everyone.
"All of Us Strangers"
is in theaters everywhere now.
Stick around. We'll be right
back with more "Late Night."